and you know we know each other we go
way back all the way to Chad science in
Newark okay Courtney kid right
I did not say that misquoted for sure
Michael B Jordan calls out a former
classmate for making fun of him and it
is awkward oh yeah I start drama over
here the whole thing went down on the
red carpet at a screening of Michael
splick Creed 3 and Atlanta after he was
approached for an interview by L'Oreal
the host of the morning hustle show who
reminded him they grew up together and
you know we know each other we go way
back all the way to Chad science and
Newark okay recording kid right
I did not say that misquoted for sure no
you did not hear me say cry I said we
used to make fun of the name but yeah he
is obviously killing things out here
yeah so that corny comment comes from a
2021 episode of the undressing room
podcast where Lori L her co-host Eva
marciel and Dominique de Diva talked
about the actor I think that Michael B
Jordan is just like a nice corny guy and
I don't mean that as a slight right I
mean we all know that the nice corny
guys treat you the best to be fair it
was actually Eva who called Michael
Corney but L'Oreal did admit that in
high school she used to make fun of him
to be honest with you we teased him all
the damn time because his name was
Michael Jordan like like let's start
there and he was no Michael Jordan and
then he also would come to school with
headshot we lived in Newark yeah like
that that's the hood you know what I
mean so it we would make fun to him like
what you gotta do with your little
stupid headshots like and now look at it
well Michael clearly caught wind of all
that horny kid right
I did not say that misquoted for sure
and L'Oreal later shared this final
moment from the uncomfortable chat
thank you
is
and while Michael isn't exactly laughing
he's not letting the childhood bullies
get him down offering this advice to
someone who's going through a tough time
to stay focused to stay locked in you
know just uh follow your heart you know
try to block out the noise and
distractions as much as possible and run
your race go don't compare yourself to
anybody else just keep going that was
Michael at the LA premiere of Creed 3 on
Monday he chatted with E.T and opened up
about the release of the film which he
starred in and directed and his new
Calvin Klein underwear ad that Calvin
Klein adds first thought when you
stopped I was like my mama gonna have to
see this let me call him I'm sorry it's
out here got my business all out in the
streets literally this is like a moment
you know just have everything kind of
coming together at one time it feels
great you know and be able to share that
moment with you know what other actors
was having a moment of their own as well
it just feels special it feels like
everything's happening the right time
seems safe to say Michael's having the
last laugh
[Music]
thank you